[Music]
[Applause]
oh no he didn't that is so harsh hey
your dad took your phone away just
forgetting a deal on the history test
yup
my mind is blown mine too I mean that
was an easy test what I can't believe
you got a D hey that's not really and
your dad is the school principal and he
took your phone away
whoa you know this isn't really helping
your life is so bleak right now well
thank you so much for your encouraging
words what did I say hey Jamela hey
friends
what's with the face of doom Valentina
have you been eating those poisonous
apples from the tree behind the
bleachers again my dad took my phone
away
yikes glad I'm not you Oh what do I have
to do to get some sympathy around here
sorry what were you saying oh never mind
[Music]
did you know about this no well this
just gets better and better unbelievable
did he just he did I'm calling my lawyer
you don't have a lawyer you're 12 years
old
oh yeah but but the point is this is
America land of the free what kind of
freedom is this
well Valentina well what what are you
going to do me last time I checked mr.
Rosario was still your dad
it was you flunking the history test
that gave him this idea in the first
place your problem you figure it out can
you believe it they confiscated my phone
because I took it out for literally four
seconds to check a text from my mom
that's just wrong I mean what if it was
a serious emergency or something right I
don't know how much longer I can take it
it's such an inconvenience to wait until
after school to check to my text or
contact my friends plus now I have to
write down my assignments which takes
forever it was so much faster to just
take a picture like do they want us to
go back to the Stone Age or what hey hey
I figured it out
what Jamila said this was my problem so
I came up with a plan this it better be
good oh it's good
you know how my dad said that he was
banning cellphones because research said
they were distracting how could I forget
but what was he doing when he said that
being an evil dictator nope he was using
reasons and evidence and that is what
we're going to do to you means that's
right we're going to write an
argumentative essay is this a joke no
it's genius you're a genius Valentina
will turn their own weapons against them
and crush them mercilessly with what a
topic sentence exactly but first we've
got to come up with a full list at
points so are you guys going to help me
or not
I'm in
jameelah fine but if this doesn't work
you're doing my homework for the next
decade
it's a deal now let's do this
[Music]